John how you doing my friend
I'm doing great Reggie how are you so
okay well let's clear this up because my
dad nets are trying to say you know it
was chip eNOS borderline was the dirty I
say you were just a hard-nosed player
well I appreciate that I think when they
say chippy I think usually that means
verbal stuff and that really wasn't my
category I know where the dirty comes
from it's dog-eat-dog out there those
pick-and-rolls when you play them on
defense big guys are holding scratch and
con nobody ever talks about that but
when you fight to get through a screen
then you're a dirty player so you know I
wear it as a badge of honor a little bit
it's a it means that you didn't just
kind of lay down and let everybody kick
you around but I certainly didn't see it
that way I mean it's a tough game it's
it's uh you know you don't play it in a
tuxedo what did you list yourself or the
media guide list us height and weight
6-1 175 pretty accurate 175 I haven't
changed much oh yeah you missed all the
bulk in the biceps red yes what's your
missing I see well let me ask you a
question obviously with all the Olympic
coverage going on you've been a member
of Dream Team 1 and 2 where are your
gold medals well they're there they're
in a safe they don't come out much I
like to bring them out if I go speak to
the kids at a school or something and
kind of let everybody reach out and
touch them they got the first one has a
few nicks on my son the very first day
swung it on his finger and hit it off a
cupboard and you know showing it around
they get a few Nicks but I'm still
pretty proud of they still shine just
very nicely so where's there a timeout
for the youngster no it was only about I
don't know two years old and my first
son grabbed it and held it running very
reverently and the second one grabbed it
like you might expect just started
swinging around we couldn't get to him
quick enough it was still in Barcelona
when that happened so it was damaged
right from the start but again it's it's
kind of a fun story and a
me little remnant you know we had a
chance to speak with Larry Bird last
hour and you know you've been a part of
the most iconic team ever assembled and
I asked him we all know what you guys
did versus the competition we saw that
walk me through because everything I
heard were the practices were the best
basketball no one had ever seen can you
tell us who was the most intense how
were the practices and how did you
approach them well I hope you mad I
broke my leg in Portland
if the tournament of Americas and so
some of those games I watched riding a
bike that was in Monte Carlo when we
were preparing there but before that and
they don't get as much press coverage
but before that when we were in Portland
it was so much fun I mean Red's you know
how it is when you're when you get you
get the opportunity to play against
great players and with great players
everything was poetry so we're in
practice and even though it was poetry
people knew where to go when to be there
how to touch the ball how to move the
ball how to cut the other side say
another nobody scorn and and every bit
is talented and not letting you score so
those were dogfights and some of some of
the best memories I have a basketball
period were those games in Portland and
you know again it's a little bit
different than what you hear about but
it's but it is for me the special time
and so is this true the only game you
guys really did lose was versus Grant
Hill and Bobby Hurley and his college
kids oh absolutely yeah
I remember that we they walked into the
game we've been practicing for a while
so when we have every excuse in the
world but but really no excuse either no
explanation these young kids walk in
after we've had a practice and I
remember Michael saying welcome to the
NBA boys right before the tip and from
that moment I was the last good thing
that happened for us they put it on us
pretty good top to bottom and you know
by the end of it it was a great shocker
can we all kind of realize that
organized motivated teams might be able
to beat us if we're not ready and from
that point forward I think we were ready
for everything so obviously this was a
teaching tool for coach Chuck Daly and
what was the locker room like after that
it was pretty quiet there wasn't a lot
of talking going on and I also remember
the next time they showed up the next
time there were no surprises whether we
paced ourselves or whatever I don't
remember what happened as far as for him
but it was quiet there wasn't a lot of
talking and the next game was kind of
like all the olympic games it was in 46
points in a hurry so you know but if I'm
on that team if I'm on that Grant Hill
team I'm pretty proud of that day
because there's nobody else that came
close who was the most intense player on
dream team one oh man I depended on the
day I mean there was a kind of the
beauty of it is everybody brought their
collective talents their individual
talents and put a little bit of the ego
aside and the point was a dogfight every
guy like you know maybe it started with
magic one day or maybe a start with
Michael Michaels pretty much you know
how he is
I mean he competes at ping-pong so you
know every day was intense and I don't
know if there was one guy that really
stood out as the fighter in it but it
was it was an agreed-upon intensity from
the start to finish we're talking with
John Stockton on the Dan Patrick show
this is the Golden Age in today's game
of the point guard when you and I played
obviously it was all about getting the
ball down low to your center and scoring
points with guys with their back to the
basket now a lot of threes it's a little
bit more flow if you look at the point
guards and how important you know
Russell Westbrook
you know Steph Curry Kyrie Irving Chris
Paul how does your game and how would if
your game would have translated in
today's game well you know the rules are
quite a bit different I mean how you can
touch a point guard I remember when I
came into the league and trying to play
against Magic Johnson he could have to
hand the forearm on you I mean he could
back you Demming all these rules you
couldn't touch a point guard out front I
mean you could you can mug them out
front you had to learn to play against
that and and now you really can't touch
guys they have more freedom of movement
they have more you know no hands on so
it's really allowed I think
the explosion of offense from that
position you can't touch him
so you can have big little you just need
to have talent can really put the ball
in the hoop part of it's unfortunate for
me I look out there nice I don't know if
I don't know if there's places for guys
like me out there and yet I think
they're missing something I think
there's a lot of great players out there
that can make their team better and win
games in droves if you have guys out
there that can bring it up pass it also
make shots do all that stuff but right
now it's just it's just get the ball in
their hands and create for yourself and
and I think it's missing something but
it's also very exciting you see Steph
Curry do what he does and and Chris Paul
and you kind of go wow can these guys
obviously Westbrook he does things that
I just marvel at every day so I don't
know it's there's trade-off things
there's a lot of ways to play the
position you see anyone challenging Team
USA I don't you know it's kind of
unfortunate that I look forward to those
games and I look forward to some team
challenging them but I don't use a lot
of the really good foreign teams if you
will a little bit older or beat-up or
little things like that so I really
don't see anybody even coming close to a
miss you John we're going to get you out
of here with this obviously we have a
poll question going on and for the
record I had nothing to do with this
poll I'm gonna let one of the Dan Nets
McLovin tell you what the poll question
is if you had a better week's pay in
their prime who would you take in a
three-point shooting contest Larry Bird
or Reggie Miller Wow that is a tough one
well man Reggie I hate to do this to you
and he comes in yeah all that easy he's
going he's the only guy that came in to
Utah when I was young player and said I
think I'm gonna have 43 tonight told our
whole team that on the bench and came in
and add forty-three tonight so I don't
know I have to give the nod to Larry at
this one don't feel bad because I was
the tiebreaker on the on the poll
question and I picked Larry legend as
well so I'm
same company so I don't feel I
appreciate you joining us thank you for
calling in
find those metals bring them out its
Olympic time you got to start showing
those Olympics medals during the
Olympics I appreciate you calling in hey
it's great talking to with you Reggie
anytime the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience